สวัสดีค่ะคุณชิสวัสดีค่ะครูอ้อย
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ทุกคนและครูอ้อย
คุณชิขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนเข้าสู่ห้อง
เรียนภาษาไทย
competable ไทยค่ะ
ค่ะแล้ววันนี้นะคะคุณชีทกับครูอ้อยเราสอง
คนเนี่ยมาเจอกันในวันอะไรคะวันอังคารค่ะ
วันนี้วันอังคารนะคะวันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่
คะ
วันอังคารที่ 27
วันที่ 27 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายนค่ะ
เดือนมิถุนายนเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเดือนที่
6 ค่ะเดือนที่ 6 ปีพุทธศักราชเท่าไหร่คะ
ปีคริสตศักราชเท่าไหร่คะ
เป็นเดือนที่ 6 ค่ะ
บีคริสต์ศักราช
2023 ปีพุทธศักราช 2566
วันนี้สบายดีค่ะครูชิแข็งแรงค่ะ
ดีใจด้วย
แล้วครูอ้อยล่ะคะสบายดีค่ะวันนี้ครูอ้อย
ก็สบายดี
ไม่ค่อยสดใสแต่ก็สบายค่ะ
กินข้าวแล้วค่ะเรียบร้อยแล้ว
[เพลง]
ค่ะครูอ้อยอยากรู้เรื่องของกูชิ
อยากมารู้เรื่องของชีวิตทำไมอ่ะ
ครูให้สงสัยไงก็เลยอยากรู้ว่ากูชิเนี่ย
ครอบครัวของคุณชิเนี่ยครอบครัวที่ทั้งพ่อ
แม่นะ
มีทั้งหมดกี่คนน่ะ
เยอะค่ะครูอ้อยเยอะ
กุชชี่เล่าให้ครูอ้อยฟังหน่อย
อ่ะเริ่มตั้งแต่ด้านคุณพ่อนะ
คุณพ่อคุชิก็มี
ปู
หญ้า
ปูหญ้า
แต่งงานกัน
แล้วก็
มีลูกใช่ไหม
ปู่ย่าเนี่ยแต่งงานกันแล้วก็มีลูก
แต่คุณปู่คิดว่าไม่ค่อยแข็งแรงอย่างมีลูก
นิดหน่อยหนึ่งสองสามมี 3 คน 3 คน
คุณปู่มีลูก 3 คน
ผู้หญิงกี่คนผู้ชายกี่คนคะผู้หญิง 1 คน
ผู้ชาย 2 คนค่ะ
มีลูก 3 คนเป็นผู้ชาย 2 คนแล้วเป็นผู้
หญิง 1 คนใช่คนไหนเป็นพ่อกูชิคนที่ 2 ค่ะ
เป็นคุณพ่อ
ถ้าอย่างนั้นครูชิก็มีลุง 1 คนใช่มี R  1
คนใช่ค่ะกุชชี่มีลุงแล้วก็มีอ่างค่ะ
แล้วฝ่ายคุณแม่ล่ะ
มี
คุณตา
คุณยาย
คุณตาคุณยายแต่งงานกันคุณตาคุณยายมีลูก
แค่ 2 คนค่ะ
2 คน
ไม่แข็งแรงเหมือนกันมีแค่ 2 คน
2 คนก็มีแม่คุณชิคนละที่เป็นผู้หญิงใช่
ค่ะแล้วน้องใช่ไหมคะ
น้อง
เป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะเป็นผู้ชายค่ะ
เป็นผู้ชายนั้นก็มีน้องชาย 1 คน
คุณแม่คุณแม่ครูชี้มีน้องชาย 1 คนค่ะ
นะคะคุณชี้เรียกน้องชายคุณแม่ว่าน้าน้า
นะแต่เรียกทางคุณพ่อน้องสาวคุณพ่อว่า
ใช่ค่ะพ่อกับแม่แต่งงานเนี่ย
ครูชี้ว่าพ่อครูชี้เนี่ยแข็งแรงค่ะ
คุณพ่อก็เลยมี 1
2  3  4  5 คุณแม่บอกพ่อพอแล้ว
พอแล้วเหนื่อย
คนนี้นะ
2 วัน
คนนี้
ปวดท้อง 3 วัน
ไม่ไหวแล้วไม่ไหวแล้ว
โอ้ยปวดท้อง 1 วันคุณแม่บอกโอเคคนนี้นะ
ปวดท้อง
ครึ่งวันค่ะครูอ้อยเออโอเคนะ
เพราะว่ามันง่ายขึ้นง่ายขึ้นไง
เออคุณแม่บอกไม่ไหวแล้วมีลูก 1  2  3  4
5 เนี่ยไม่ไหวแล้วเหนื่อยเหนื่อย
ทีนี้แล้วแล้วคุณชี้คนที่เท่าไหร่ล่ะคะ
คนที่ 3 ค่ะ
[เพลง]
ผู้ที่ 3
ที่เขียนเลขด้วยจะได้รู้ว่าคนที่ 3 แล้ว
คุชชี่เนี่ยมีพี่ซึ่งอยู่ข้างบนคุณ
ชิเนี่ยเป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายมีพี่สาว 1
คนมีพี่ชาย 1 คนค่ะ
แล้วน้องล่ะคะ
มีน้องสาว 1 คนค่ะน้องชาย 1 คนค่ะ
งั้นแสดงว่าคุณชี้เนี่ยมีพี่น้องทั้งหมด 5
คนใช่ค่ะ 5 คน
1 คนน้องชาย 1 คนใช่ค่ะ
มีทั้งน้องสาวน้องชายพี่ชายพี่สาวมีครบ
[เพลง]
ทุกอย่างค่ะ
แล้วย่าตายายลุงอ้าลุงคุชิก็มีแตนแตนๆ
แต่งงานค่ะ
ครูอ้อยกำลังจะบอกกูชิไม่มีป้า
ที่มีป้าค่ะคุณลุงแต่งงานครูชิก็เรียก
ภรรยาของคุณลุงว่าป้า
[เพลง]
มีน้าค่ะ
เราเรียกลุงแต่ถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงเราเรียกป้า
แต่ถ้าเป็นน้องของพ่อนะถ้าเป็นผู้ชายหรือ
ผู้หญิงเราเรียกอ่า
แต่ทางฝั่งคุณแม่แต่คุณแม่ทางฝั่งคุณแม่
คุณชิตไม่มีลุงและไม่มีป้าไม่มีค่ะคุณแม่
ไม่มีพี่ชายไม่มีพี่สาวไม่มี
ไม่มีแต่คุณแม่คุณมีน้องนะคะแต่มีน้องคน
เดียวเป็นผู้ชายไม่ใช่เรียกน้องของคุณแม่
ว่าน้าค่ะน้าไม่ว่าจะเป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้
ชายกุชชี่ก็เรียกน้าใช่ไหมคะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยครูชิมี
ญาติๆอันนี้เรียกว่าญาติๆกูชิเยอะ
คือหญ้าตายายลุงป้าน้าอาพ่อแม่
นายเลยพี่ชายน้องสาวน้องชาย
พี่สาวพี่ชายตัวครูชิน้องสาวน้องชายใช่
ค่ะ
อยากรู้มากกว่านี้อยากรู้อะไรคะโอ้โหคุณ
ชิเนี่ยทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
อาชีพอะไรคะ
ชาวประมง
จับปลา
หาเรือออกไปทะเลแล้วก็ไปจับปลา
จับมาขายใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะครูอ้อยจับมาขายนะ
คุณปู่เป็นชาวประมงใช่ค่ะ
ถ้างั้นคุณย่าล่ะคุณจิคุณย่าคืออะไร
คุณย่าคุณชี้เป็นช่างตัดผมค่ะ
อย่างนี้เลย
ใช่
เป็นช่างตัดผมค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะ
อันนี้
คุณยากแต่คนนี้ไม่ใช่คุณย่านะคะเอารูปมา
ให้ดูว่าช่างตัดผม
ตอนคุณย่าคุณ
เป็นแบบนี้เลยใช่ไหม
คุณย่าคุณปู่
จริงๆอ่า
ชาวประมงคุณย่าทำอาชีพเป็นช่างตัดผม
แล้วคุณลุงคุณชิล่ะคะ
คุณลุงเป็นตำรวจค่ะ
ดีจังเลยเป็นตำรวจ
ถ้างั้นคุณลุงคุณที่นี่แต่งงานกับคุณป้า
คุณป้าทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
คุณป้าคุชิเนี่ยแน่นอนค่ะ
พอแต่งงานกับตำรวจคุณป้าครูชี้เป็นนัก
เขียนค่ะเป็นนักเขียน
อ๋อคุณชี้เหมือน JK  rowling ใช่ไหมเขียน
Harry  Potter
ไม่ได้แบบรวยเหมือนเหมือนเขาอ่ะ
นะ
คุณป้าเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนเป็นนักเขียน
ดีมากเลย
เป็นนักเขียน
คุณป้าเป็นนักเขียนคุณลุงเป็นตำรวจ
แล้วพ่อกูชิล่ะคะ
เพราะกูชี้หน้าเป็น
ทหาร
เป็นทหารแต่ในภาพเนี่ยไม่ใช่ทหารบกไม่ใช่
ทหารอากาศแต่นั่งเรือ
เป็นทหารเรือใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
ทหารมี 3 อย่างหนึ่งพาหะเรือ
อาหารเรือ
และก็ 2
ทหารบก
[เพลง]
ทหารบกก็ต้องมีรถถังมีปืน
ทหารบกและ 3
ทหารอากาศ
ทหารอากาศอันนี้ F16
เป็นทหารอากาศค่ะ
เห็นไหมแต่คุณพ่อกุชชิไม่ใช่ทหารอากาศไม่
ใช่ทหารบกแต่เป็นทหารเรือค่ะทหารเรือคุณ
พ่อคงจะเคยนั่งเรือไปกับคุณปู่หาปลาเลย
ชอบ
อ้อยรู้
ไอคิวดีคุณอ้อ
[เพลง]
คุณพ่อเป็นทหารเรืออ้าวแล้วน้องคุณพ่อล่ะ
คะ
น้องคุณพ่อ
คุณอาคุชินเนี่ยเป็นนักข่าว
นักข่าว
อย่าง CNN ใช่ไหม
ข่าวช่อง 3
อ้าวแล้วทีนี้พอฟังคุณพ่อหมดแล้วนะไปฝั่ง
คุณแม่บ้าง
คุณแม่
ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
คุณตาครูชี้นะ
คุณยายทำอาชีพอะไร
กูชิเนี่ยเคยถามคุณแม่ค่ะครูอ้อยคุณแม่
บอกไม่รู้เพราะว่าคุณตาคุณยายเนี่ยตาย
ตั้งแต่คุณแม่ครูเด็กๆตอนคุณแม่ 3
ขวบค่ะ
คุณแม่ 3 ขวบคุณตาคุณยายตายแล้ว
คุณแม่ 3 ขวบเนี่ยจำไม่ได้ไม่รู้คุณตาคุณ
ยายอาชีพอะไรคะ
ครูชิก็เลยไม่รู้ค่ะครูอ้อยไม่รู้
ถ้าอย่างนั้นก็ต้องถามแล้วคุณแม่คุณชิทำ
อาชีพอะไร
คุณแม่ครูชิเนี่ยเป็นแม่ค้าค่ะขายปลา
เป็นแม่ค้าขายปลาที่ตลาดเนี่ยค่ะ
คุณ
ชิบอกคุณปู่หาปลาไง
หาปลามาแล้วคุณแม่ก็ขายปลา
คุณแม่เป็นแม่ค้าขายปลา
แม่ปลากิโลละเท่าไหร่เห็นไหมขายที่ตลาด
คุณแม่เป็นแม่ค้าใช่ค่ะ
แล้วคุณแม่มีน้องสาวใช่ไหมคะ
น้องสาวหรือน้องชาย
เป็นน้อง
ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
ถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปผู้หญิงถ่ายรูปทะเลอย่าง
เงี้ยใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
น้าคุชิเป็นช่างภาพช่างภาพเป็นช่างภาพค่ะ
ครูอ้อย
โอ้โหถ้าอย่างนั้นครัวต้องถามกลับมาใน
ครอบครัวของคุณชิระจากพ่อแม่แล้วมาที่พี่
น้องใช่ไหม
พี่น้องทั้ง 5 คนของคุชิเนี่ยเริ่มตั้ง
แต่พี่คนโตซึ่งเป็นพี่สาว
พี่สาวครูชิตทำอาชีพอะไร
พี่สาวกูชิเนี่ยทำอาชีพเหมือนคุณพ่อค่ะ
เป็น
ทหารเรือทหารเรือ
เป็นผู้หญิงเราเรียกทหารเรือหญิงใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
เป็นทหารเรือค่ะทหาร
อ้าวแล้วพี่ชาย
ทำอาชีพ
พี่ชายกูชิทำอาชีพเหมือนๆคุณแม่
เป็นขายของขายหมูหรอ
แม่เนี่ยเป็นผู้หญิง
ไม่ว่าจะขายอะไรที่เป็น Max เราก็เรียก
แม่ค้าเป็นผู้หญิงแต่พอผู้ชายมาขายของเรา
เราก็เรียกพ่อค้า
แต่แม่ขายปลาใช่ค่ะ
พี่ชายขายหมู
ขายอยู่ที่ตลาดเหมือนกันเลยใช่ไหม
ขายอยู่ที่ตลาด
ตลาด
คนไทยนะ
คนไทย
ที่ตลาดก็มีขายทุกอย่างขายผักผลไม้เนื้อ
สัตว์ทุกอย่าง
มีผักใช่ไหม
ผักผลไม้
ทีนี้ก็เลยมาถึงคุชิแล้ว
คุณชิเนี่ยตอนนี้ปัจจุบันเนี้ย
เป็นครู
แต่ครูอ้อยอ่ะรู้ว่าคุชชี่ไม่ได้ทำอาชีพ
ครูอาชีพเดียว
เมื่อก่อนคุณเชื่อทำอะไรคะทำอาชีพอะไร
เมื่อก่อนคุชิตทำอาชีพไกด์ค่ะครูอ้อย
อาชีพก็มัคคุเทศก์ใช่ค่ะ
เป็นมัคคุเทศก์พาคนเนี่ยไปเที่ยว
ไปเที่ยวค่ะ
พาคนต่างชาติหรือหรือคนไทยก็ได้ถ้าจะไป
เที่ยวเป็นกลุ่มใหญ่ๆตั้งแต่ 5 คน 6 คน
หรือ 10 คนก็จะมีกุชชี่เนี่ยหรือไม่ก็ไป
ถูกไมโครโฟนหรือ
ธงขณะนี้เราอยู่ที่วัดวัดโพธิ์วัดโพธิ์
กำแพงนี้สร้างมาตั้งแต่สมัย
อย่างนี้ใช่ไหม
เวลานัดนัดคนมาเที่ยวนะ
มองดูธงสีส้ม
มารวม
เวลากี่โมง
แล้วก็หลังจากแต่งงาน
ก็มาเป็นครูเป็นครู
เป็นครู
อ่ะแล้วน้องสาวครูปุ๊ก
น้องสาวคุชิก็เป็นครูค่ะ
เหมือนครูชิเลย
ใช่ค่ะ
เป็นครูเหมือนกัน
ใช่ค่ะครูอ้อย
อันนี้อันนั้นไม่ใช่กูชิหรือน้องสาวกูชิ
ไหม
สวย
สวยใช่ไหม
เป็นครูทีนี้เรารู้และเรารู้ 4 คนแล้ว
เหลือคนสุดท้ายคือน้องชายน้องชายทำอาชีพ
อะไรคะ
น้องชายครูชี้แนะเป็นนักดนตรีค่ะ
ไปเล่นดนตรีร้องเพลง
แต่น้องชาย
เลยนะ
มีครอบครัวถูกต้องครูอ้อยทำอาชีพไม่
เหมือนใคร
เพราะอาชีพนักดนตรีเนี่ย
เขาจะทำงานกลางคืนเป็นส่วนใหญ่
คนนี้ทำงานตอนกลางคืน
ตอนกลางคืน
อันนี้พระจันทร์
มืดๆ
แล้วพอตอนกลางวันก็นอนใช่ค่ะพระอาทิตย์
พระอาทิตย์ขึ้นตอนกลางวัน
นอน
ค่ะ
แต่พอตอนกลางคืน
ทำงาน
หลายอาชีพนะ
คะ
[เพลง]
แล้วคุณย่าคุณย่าเป็นช่างตัดผมค่ะ
ช่างตัดผม
คุณลุงคุณลุงคุชิเนี่ยเป็นตำรวจคุณลุง
เป็นตำรวจ
เป็นตำรวจค่ะคุณป้าล่ะคะคุณป้า
เขียนนักเขียนเหมือน JK  rowling
ตัวคุณพ่อคุณ
คุณพ่อเป็นทหารเรือค่ะอาหารเรือ
ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วคุณนะของกุชชี่นะคะ
คุณคุณน้าใช่ไหม
คุณแม่เป็นแม่ค้าขายปลาค่ะขายปลาเป็นแม่
ค้า
คุณน้าคุณน้าเป็นช่างภาพ
เป็นช่างภาพค่ะช่างภาพ
นะคะช่างภาพ
พี่สาวล่ะคะ
พี่สาวกู้ชีพเนี่ยเหมือนคุณพ่อค่ะเป็น
ทหารเรือหญิง
ทหารเรือใช่ค่ะ
พี่ชายค่ะ
พี่ชายเป็นพ่อค้าขายหมูค่ะ
พี่ชายเป็นพ่อค้า
ขายหมู
ใช่ค่ะ
ชิตอนนี้เป็นครูก่อนหน้านั้น
[ปรบมือ]
ตอนนี้เป็นครูตอนนี้เป็นครูค่ะน้องสาวครู
ให้ค่ะ
[เพลง]
แล้วน้องชาย
น้องชายครูชี้แนะเป็นนักดนตรี
นักดนตรีใช่ค่ะอันนี้ก็เป็นครอบครัวของ
ครูชิแล้วก็เป็นอาชีพของครอบครัวคุชิค่ะ
ก็บางคนก็ทำอาชีพเหมือนๆกันบางคนก็ทำ
อาชีพไม่เหมือนกันค่ะครูอ้อยบางคนก็ทำ
อาชีพเขาเรียกอะไรอย่างคุณปู่หาปลาคุณแม่
เอาไปขาย
รับกันนะคุณปู่เป็นชาวประมงจับปลาคุณแม่
ก็ขายปลาเป็นแม่ค้า
เป็นตำรวจตำรวจพ่อก็เป็นทหาร
ตำรวจทหาร
อูฐทางฝั่งคุณปู่คุณย่าเนี่ย
รู้สึกว่าทำข้าราชการกันเนาะหมายถึงว่า
เป็นทั้งตำรวจและทหารเนาะ
ไม่ชอบรับราชการไม่อยากเป็นตำรวจไม่อยาก
เป็นทหารคุณอาก็เลยมาเป็นนักข่าวค่ะ
นักข่าวข่าว
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะ
ท่านนายก
เป็นนักข่าวค่ะนักข่าวนะ
ส่วนคุณน้าคุณน้าครูชิเนี่ยเป็นช่างภาพ
จริงๆช่างภาพก็อาจจะไปกับนักข่าวได้นะ
ถ้าเขาทำงานที่เดียวกันนะไปถ่ายถ่ายรูป
เออใช่เพราะว่า
ไปพูดอย่างเดียวไปถามอย่างเดียวต้องมีรูป
ประกอบภาพด้วย
นะ
บางทีต้องไปถ่ายวีดีโอบางทีต้องไปถ่ายรูป
แชะๆต้องอาศัยช่างภาพค่ะ
[เพลง]
คิดว่าคุณอากับคุณน้าทำงานด้วยกันได้นะ
ใช่น่าจะทำงานด้วยกันได้
เป็นช่างตัดผมเนี่ยมีร้านไหมคะ
ไม่มีค่ะ
คุณย่าเนี่ยไม่เปิดร้านค่ะแต่คุณย่าเป็น
ช่างตัดผมที่แบบว่าหิ้วมีตะกร้าใช่ไหม
แล้วก็ติ๊งหน่องตัดผมไหมคะ
ไปตามบ้าน
ใช่ค่ะก็น่าจะใกล้ๆบ้านนะไม่ได้ไปไกลจาก
หมู่บ้านสมมุติหมู่บ้านนึงแถวนั้นมีสัก
ประมาณ
10 หลังคา 10 หลัง 10 หลัง
จะพูดหลังคาตรงนั้นเดี๋ยวย่างไป
10 หลัง
[เพลง]
ตัดผมไหมคะ
บางทีเนี่ยบ้านนี้บอกโอ้
ช่างตัดผมเหรอคะตัดผมด้วยมี 1 คนผู้ชายมี
2 คนผู้หญิงอยากตัดผมคุณย่าบอกโอเค
เฮ้ยแต่เมื่อก่อนนะครูอ้อยตัดผมนะย่าตัด
ผมไม่แพงค่ะ
อืม
เมื่อประมาณเอ่อ
10 ปีที่แล้ว
แล้วสมัยก่อนไม่ต้องมีอุปกรณ์มากไม่ต้อง
มีเครื่องมือ
5 บาท
ค่ะตอนนี้ตัดผม 100 บาทใช่ไหม
100 บาทแต่เมื่อก่อนคุณย่าตัดผมค่ะ
5 บาทค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะ 5 บาทเนี่ยกินข้าวได้ 2 แล้วนะ
1  2 กินข้าวได้ 2 จานนะ
สมัยก่อนนะ
สมัย
ครูอ้อยยังไม่เกิดอ่ะ
ยังไม่อ้วนนะ
[เพลง]
ไม่มีร้านค่ะ
ไม่มีร้านแบบเปิดร้านแล้วก็มีคนคนมาแล้ว
ก็ตัดผมค่ะไม่มีเมื่อก่อนคุณย่าเนี่ยเดิน
ค่ะ
เดินๆเดินแล้วก็ติ๊งหน่องตัดผมไหมคะ
อืมตัดผมไหมคะ
อือ
แต่ก็มีนะครูอ้อยบางทีคุณย่าคุณชี้อ่ะ
อยู่ที่บ้านค่ะแต่มีคนเนี่ยมาหาคุณย่าที่
บ้าน
ที่จริงเนี่ยคุณย่าไม่ต้องออกไปข้างนอกก็
ได้
คุณย่าอยู่ที่บ้านก็มีคนมาตัดใช่ค่ะหลังๆ
เนี่ยคุณย่าเนี่ยไม่ไปติ๊งหน่องติ๊งหน่อง
ก็มีคนแบบมาหาคุณย่าที่บ้านคิดถึงอ่ะทำไม
ไม่ไปตัดผมไม่ไปติ๊งหน่องติ๊งหน่องแล้ว
ล่ะคุณย่าบอกโอ๋ๆแก่แล้วเดินไม่ไหว
แล้วเขาก็เลยมาบ้านกูชิมาให้คุณย่าตัดผม
ให้
ค่ะโอเคไหมครูอ้อยรู้จักครอบครัว
รู้หมดแล้วว่าใครทำอะไรทำอาชีพอะไรบ้าง
ครูอ้วนรู้หมดแล้วทุกคน
ครูอ้อยเนี่ย
รู้อาชีพของของครอบครัว
ไปทำไมคะครูอ้อยเนี่ยเป็นนักสืบเหรอโช๊ค
Home หรอคะ
บอกแล้วไง
อยากรู้อือแต่ตอนนี้ไม่บอกทำไมกูก็อยาก
รู้เพราะว่าเวลาหมดแล้ว
ครูอ้อยเนี่ยเหมือนๆแบบเป็นนักสืบแบบ
เชอร์ล็อคโฮมอาชีพนักสืบ
อาชีพนักสืบ
[เพลง]
วันนี้
ขอบคุณนักเรียนและขอบคุณครูชิที่มาตอบคำ
ถามครูอ้อยเรื่องครอบครัว
แล้วขอบคุณนักเรียนนะครับพบกันใหม่คลาส
หน้า
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ขอบคุณค่ะ